bonsoir colette brosset bonsoir robert
dhéry robert dhéry pensez-vous être le
conjoint idéal et vous colette brosset
non
[Musique]
robert dhéry vous souvenez vous de la
date de votre mariage et vous connaître
bruxelles 18 novembre
[Musique]
êtes vous ordonnez robert et il ordonné
maniaque
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous réveillez vous de bonne humeur oui
plutôt
robert se révèle-t-il de bonne humeur
merci robert dhéry merci que les brosses
et à bientôt
[Musique]
amy téléspectateurs et spectateurs du
théâtre sang de bonsoir
et alors réponses à ces questions très
rapide et un peu indiscrètes nous avons
pu justifier du même coup le titre un
peu déroutant au départ de notre
émission la vie à deux et pourtant et
pourtant toutes les réussites des
couples qui vont se succéder dans notre
jeu tient dans cette formule en effet
s'il est parfois difficile d'avoir un
avis personnel lorsqu'il s'agit de
l'avoir à 2 et le même de préférence est
encore beaucoup plus compliqué voilà
pourquoi on peut dire que avoir les
mêmes pour avoir les mêmes joies les
mêmes espérances les mêmes réactions les
mêmes fans wars si les mêmes mains pour
les mêmes voisins mais aussi les mêmes
projets les mêmes plaisirs
c'est finalement être heureux c'est en
quelque sorte composer un couple idéal
cette fois ci on peut dire c'est voir la
vie veilleux en août
voilà pourquoi nous avons pensé qu'il
serait peut-être sympathique de
récompenser les couples les mieux unis
après tout depuis le temps que nous
récompensons ceux qui connaissent sur le
bout des doigts l'arbre généalogique des
mérovingiens où le nombre de boutons jet
des grognards de la gare pourquoi ne pas
récompenser le monsieur qui connaît les
fleurs préférées de madame et c'est lui
en offrir de temps à autre ou les posent
l'épousé idéale qui sait d'un geste ou
d'une parole calme et la mauvaise humeur
de monsieur voilà et bien d'ailleurs ce
pourrait peut-être servir à beaucoup
d'entre nous en tous les cas j'espère
que ce soir les deux premiers couples
sélectionnés vont nous donner raison
il s'agit pour le couple numéro un que
nous allons applaudir d'ailleurs toute
sympathie d hier monsieur
cliquer le seul impliqué prénom gérard
pour le mieux si évident pour la dame 26
ans pour le monsieur 28 ans je crois
pour la dame 1 et vous avez des enfants
des enfants marié pour le même temps
cinq ans l'un des enfants un petit
garçon de quatre ans qui s'appelle
olivier une petite fille de 3 ans qui
s'appelle anne dont le la profession de
cieux d'ailleurs monsieur cliquer ce
sera l'occasion pour vous de vous
pencher vers madame puisque vous avez
amis groupe qui voyaient déjà une
tendance féminine regarder les porter
vers des lachinois trois précisions je
suis le viseur de 10 heures what is it
c'est à dire que j'établis dépouilles
des z a fait un devis pour ces missions
nous sommes le premier le rtf ne peux je
m'en faire bon eh bien écoutez je pense
que nous avons tout le temps de faire
connaissance au cours de cette émission
elle est faite pour vous voulez vous
maintenant je vous prie de m'excuser
adams et moment de la séparation elle
n'est pas définitive rassurez vous voici
notre charmante hôtesse juliette qui va
maintenant combien monsieur dans sa
cabine à titre est bien chaude bien
insonorisé assez inconfortable mais vous
ne resterez pas toute votre vie qui me
permet maintenant de me tourner vers
monsieur et madame markov que nous
applaudissons bien sur terre
écoute légèrement plus âgés mais
tellement peu vous avez quel âge même si
markov parler très fort vers j'ai 36 ans
bon je ne demande pas l'âge de madame on
peut vous êtes encore toutes chaudes des
enfants deux enfants aux enfants une
fille nathalie 10 ans et alexis sept ans
nous a laissés partir comme ça votre
profession je marque
j 6 ingénieurs des ventes ingénieurs de
vente mais je répète parce que je crois
que vous n'avez pas peut-être tendance à
vous pensiez c'est un siège non parce
qu'elle va pas le faire longtemps parce
que ces machins moment de la séparation
mais moi je voudrais vous poser une
petite question avant qui a décidé de
participer à cette émission assez ma
femme ah c'est vous qui prenez des
décisions censées prévenir mon mari
d'ailleurs non et alors vous vous
retrouvez là ce soir sans savoir asile
assumé par la civic faisaient passer
devant la maison de leur thèse qui avait
de la lumière il y avait du monde et on
va rentrer à la patiente et gardeur
tranquille allez dans le passé ce petit
quart d'heure en exercice à monsieur
markov conduite par notre ravissante
france a cette fois ci après la blonde
la brune dans votre cabine à titrer que
ceux qui payent le permet immédiatement
de gagner le premier fauteuil rendu
libre puisque notre premier test
êtes-vous d'accord est un test très
agréable je vous retrouve mana et vous
n'êtes pas un premier test
bon eh bien vous savez d'ailleurs je
vais demander tout de suite à juliette
de nous montre un écureuil je ne vous
abandonne pas prétendre à markov qu'à
chacun de nos tests ou thomas dans les
tests du début
l'équipe gagnante le couple gagnant
gagnera un écureuil et en fin de
parcours si l'on peut dire ce sera
peut-être deux écureuils
c'est très important parce que ce sera
le couple qui aura totalisé le plus
d'écureuils qui tout naturellement sera
vainqueur l'autre sera éliminé et oui il
ya quand même des risques alors notre
premier test
maintenant s'il vous plaît merci
juliette notre premier test va nous
permettre de vérifier l'insonorisation
de nos cabines monsieur pliquet brancher
la cabine m'entendais vous me répondez
monsieur oui oui oui mais parlait très
bien parfaitement vous n'êtes pas bien
alors maintenant vous coupez la cabine
vous enrayer un petit
sont très désagréables pour qu'il
entende plus rien voilà est-ce que vous
m'accordez encore monsieur appliquée je
suis rassuré comme aurait dit oui toutes
les missions étaient couchés par terre
alors à partir de maintenant madame en
toute intimité je vous poser trois
questions
si votre sympathique et pour répondre la
même manière à ces trois questions ou
c'est bien parti pour le premier écueil
mais bien entendu il y aura la réplique
de nos amis monsieur madame markov
qu'elle est de vous deux bien sûr vous
coupez la cabine à n'oubliez surtout pas
qu'elle est le plus cachottier de vous
deux je crois que si moi c'est vous will
enregistrer votre mari est il content de
son physique boîte de faire un gros plan
sur l'île en ce temps là oui oui il est
content de son physique j'entends j'y
tiens et d'un seul coup le décide et de
le cas au moment où paraît de son
physique et des curiosités on y est déjà
dans cette première liste et qui est le
plus qu'à l'un des deux ça c'était la
question la plus à risque
c'est lui bon alors je résume vous êtes
la plus cachée pied oui il est très
content de son physique très content lui
assez content de son facebook
oui moi je pense pas du vaudou
judiciaire il sera malgré tout c'est le
plus qu'à lancer nuit chabert alors un
juliette libéré maintenant notre
sympathique monsieur piqué à s'impliquer
qui est le plus qu à châtier de vous
deux
je crois que c'est moi
êtes vous content de votre physique oui
ça me pose pas de problème
bon ben voilà pour moi de ce côté là
nous sommes tranquilles
et enfin quel est le plus qu'à l'un des
deux c'est moi a finalement il ya 2 sur
3 c'est pas mauvais comme score est bien
très vite
markov c'est vraiment très agréable vous
voyez du bruit de l'une à l'autre et
c'est très agréable en même temps d'être
prêt de charmante épouse alors que les
bars ils sont complètement enfermé alors
nous faisons un petit essai avec cette
2e cabine monsieur marc vous m'entendez
monsieur madoff
oui on se rappelait très bien très bien
vous voulez vous coupez la cabine envoyé
le même son voilà monsieur marco vous
m'entendez toujours parfait alors madame
markov part ça c'est fini les envoie
même pu se terminer
quel est le plus sévère de vous deux
avec les enfants oh c'est mon mari votre
mari oui oui lorsque les enfants signe
le pot de confiture
celui-ci ce sévère qui a le plus
confiance en l'autre je crois que si
c'est bien sûr une question
embarrassante
hilali votre tous les deux ensemble oui
mais ça il faut tout d un jeu facile du
jeu c'est que vous soyez contrainte de
prendre une décision
des mois peut-être vous êtes confiance
en lui qu'il a confiance en vous
peut-être un voile une chose qu'il
faudra éclaircir plus tard et enfin qui
revient le premier après une dispute
moi toujours à toutes les vertus
pauvre monsieur markov qu'on va
maintenant libérés chez marks of wwii
qui est le plus sévère avec ses enfants
or je crois que c'est moi il le j'ai le
plus confiance en l'autre on écoute et
je crois que c'est la cip rock oui mais
ça j'ai déjà été très près a fallu
prendre position pardon oui mais
maintenant on prend une décision on peut
je crois que j'ai entière confiance
serait femmes enfin c'est à dire que
vous avez finalement plus confiance en
elle qu'elle en vous oui disons oui
c'est bien oui c'est bien ça oui c'est
bien oui bon mais enfin qui revient le
premier après une dispute en c'est ma
femme bombes et les étudiantes et bien
j'ai l'impression que nous avons un très
brillant match nul depuis les toits
voilà en tous les cas deux écureuils qui
vont arriver dans les mains de nos
ravissantes gp
m
le deuxième test avez-vous les mêmes
goûts et bien en avant première de
l'élection de miss france 1971 qui aura
lieu le 31 décembre
affronter le régime vous allez avoir le
privilège regarder grâce aux caméras
bregy pradines grâce au comité miss
france de juger
trois des 30 candidats déjà sélectionné
je vous en dirai un peu plus tout à
l'heure pour le moment fait entrer les
miss et admirer les surtout ne coupez
pas le faire mais pas de rideaux de ces
messieurs
[Applaudissements]
voici miss franche comté
[Musique]
ok et miss bordeaux d'ailleurs je vais
donner leur nom myriam stocco et miss
languedoc daniel la bouger et miss
franche comté et nadine labaki wolf miss
bordeaux
[Musique]
regardez bien mesdames regarder surtout
bien messieurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
taga et bien maintenant vous fermez les
rideaux
ces messieurs on en a assez vu et vous
allez maintenant mesdames essayer de
deviner je dis bien deviné le goût le
choix de vos maris dans cette pré
élection de miss france 1971
tout d'abord madame markov celle du
milieu c'est du plagiat tel le dia non à
celle du milieu
mademoiselle commence mademoiselle
languedoc musée cocteau madame me
piquent les mines les landes
c'est jean louis ont volé les rideaux
[Musique]
voilà monsieur markov votre charmante
épouse a tenté de deviner votre choix
dans cette pré élection qu'elle est
celle de ses trois ravissantes créatures
à qui vous donnez votre voix écoutez le
choyer difficile mais oui je vous vois
vous penchez vous allez voir un
torticolis tomber parce que je n'ai rien
vu de je préfère la demoiselle du milieu
l oise 1 2 million monsieur py klein
votre épouse a tenté de vider votre goût
quel est votre goût dans cette élection
eh bien sans chercher de limiter moi
aussi la demoiselle du milieu oui c'est
à dire que vous avez entendu le choix de
markov
ce n'était peut-être pas forcément celui
de renom mais enfin ceci bon eh bien
vous avez encore gagné tous les deux
merci mademoiselle d'ailleurs
que le choix était bien difficile
elles sont absentes ces deux écureuils
que vous avez gagné
eh bien vous être remis par miss france
1970 micheline bourrin la majesté en
titre
[Musique]
voilà avec l'uruguay va là et voici
l'autre écureuils comme ça il n'y aura
pas de jaloux
merci majesté et bien tandis que
micheline bora nous quitte voici notre
troisième set avez-vous comment fait-il
plus exactement comment comment fait-il
et bien mesdames
est-ce que vous avez des problèmes quand
ces messieurs rentre fatigué le soir et
qu'il se déchausse hâtivement et bien
grâce aux pieds aimablement prêtée par
notre ami maurice baquet vous allez
découvrir maintenant grâce au télé
cinéma
nous allons essayer de reconstituer les
trois manières de se déchausser pour les
hommes fatigués il est 20h30
monsieur marc coffrante monsieur pique
les rentes
ils sont fatigués ils sont harassés vous
êtes à la cuisine il se demande comment
il va se déchaussent et maurice baquet
va vous présenter trois manières la
première étant celle du soyeux
[Musique]
première manière
et c'est gai mesdames de savoir quelle
est celle qu'utilise votre époux thomas
la plus approchante
quand même un cas très rare celui là je
trouve ça en fin de deuxième manière le
négliger
[Musique]
à
un peu ma manière ça voyez vous pas pour
le fauteuil pour avant troisième manière
l'un des six
[Musique]
voilà ça ça finit sur la table c'est
pour vous mesdames
alors nous ferme le rideau est
maintenant que vos époux ont pu voir ce
trois manières madame le pic n'est
qu'elle est celle tout on va là plus
approchant des manières utilisé par
monsieur py clé je crois que c'est
plutôt la première manière c'est un
soigneux ou est plutôt chaleureuse
hommes
madame marcotte
moi je fais de la culture physique dans
cette émission alors quel est l'avenir
c'est la même chance cet avis est
sûrement celle qui fut vraiment dit la
prise en charge
j'ai l'impression pourtant qu'il doit y
avoir quelques maris qui se sont
reconnus ce soir nous libérons monsieur
markov
voici trois manières monsieur markov que
vous avez vues sur votre petit écran qui
se trouve dans votre cabine vient quelle
est celle que vous croyez être la bonne
enfin qui vous concerne la vôtre en jeu
quand je ne vais pas hésiter c'est la
première et monsieur pickler bas au
risque de copier une nouvelle fois c'est
quand même la première mais sans le
mouchoir mais je vous promets que la
prochaine fois je vous interrogera en
premier parce que vous avez l'air de
toujours copié sur monsieur marc
effective et bien encore un mec qui
règne partout mais bon c'est un match
regardez voici le score avez vous encore
les mêmes goûts voici mesdames
maintenant trois robes créées à votre
attention par le couturier le plus
génialement excentrique et original jean
bouquin vous allez essayer d'imaginer si
vous sortez ce soir ou demain ou
après-demain au bras de votre mari dans
quelle robe vous aimeriez être pour
participer à cette soirée de pure
imagination
alors vous voyez que nos mannequins ont
des cartes à jouer
ça c'est pour brouiller les cartes c'est
le cas de le dire et lorsque vous aurez
fait votre choix
on laisse un petit peu nos nos époux
admirer les mannequins de jean bouquin
tirer les rideaux et maintenant les
dames très vite
voulez vous nous dire en ce qui concerne
madame pic l'est quelle est la robe que
vous choisissez la retenir une donnée
l'as de carreau le 9 de trèfle ou leroy
pic
l'avez vous si vous voulez le mourre le
roi de nomades pierre leroy ces droits
soient les mêmes marqueurs là également
c'est bien dommage mais on va voir si
des marines est morale fille olive et
voilà que les époux skopelos libérer
monsieur cliquer libérer le cieux markov
monsieur pliquet je ne peux plus
interroge en premier quelle est la robe
choisie par madame pic lait sur les
trois choisis par l as we will à celle
inverse
bongo je pense que c'est la première
c'est à dire la personne qui tenait un
des indices de trêve je crois à 9,9 de
13 peut-être la personne qui avait une
robe encore regardé venez jusqu'à la
porte de monsieur piqué pour être
certain monsieur oui c'est très bien est
certain c'est celle-là oui monsieur
markov
oui si markov quelle est la robe choisie
par madame markov ont écouté j'hésite
côté jeu doit copier monsieur n'y a pas
de problème c'est je pense que c'est le
la robe le trèfle allée mademoiselle est
aussi devant la cabine de monsieur
markov
voilà bah je peux dire mademoiselle que
vous sortirez avec ces deux messieurs
mais que les charmantes épouses
sortiront avec moi car ça ne sera pas
les mêmes robes
alors là ont ils sont encore infectés
coup mais malheureusement on leur donne
pas d'écureuils
mais on applaudit nos mannequins merci
un petit regard sur le score est bien à
trois partout dit moi nous allons vers
un match nul
vous devez jouer au rugby tous les deux
parce que je crois c'est 3 partout c'est
un score de rugby voici notre test
numéro 5 comment auriez-vous vous allez
voir un gag film et d'un extrait du
petit baigneur ce qui nous permettra de
donner un second coup de chapeau à
robert dhéry que nous avons d'ailleurs
accueilli au début de cette première
émission mais robert n'est pas dans
cette scène c'est jacques legras qui en
est le héros et louis de funès qu'on
aperçoit vous allez devoir pour cela et
les hôtesses vous remettre mesdames des
chiffres de 1 à 9
messieurs regarder si dans vos cabine
vous avez les mêmes chiffres
à la manière si l'on peut dire d vous
savez des juges au patinage artistique
donner un coefficient pour voir si vous
riez de la même manière
attention mais se porte pour tout de
suite télé cinéma
c'est de l'humilier j'avais quitté cette
terre et j'arrivais et j'arrivais au
mali pour écouter on paie habitait saint
pierre kim avait reconnu me demanda vous
êtes bien l'abbé castanet je répondis
oui mais je remarquais sur ses lèvres un
sourire
monsieur le curé
savez vous comment ton appel votre
église ici non c'est non on grand saint
pierre on l'appelle notre-dame des
courants d'air je ne répèterai pas je ne
répèterai pas le navrant d'amendé qui
saute aux yeux
l'état des charbons le toit ont le
bourdon et les croquis très donner
l'exemple
les statuts cette chère elle même
[Musique]
j'ai fini je reviendrai plus loin
monseigneur est bien plus célébrés les
cérémonies de la scène confirmation vous
ne vous êtes jamais demandé qu'on croit
la dernière fois qu'il est venu il a
attrapé une bronchite
mademoiselle vos pieds nous a quittés
pour toujours à la suite d'une pneumonie
l'harmonium resterait sont presque vides
roubaix il joue comme il peut le faut
ainsi je suis le curé de notre-dame des
courants d'air et je me surprends dié je
me dis qu'il ya sur ma terre d'être être
rude
elle conte collègues de paris qu'à notre
d'art que je n'ai jamais eu le plaisir
de rencontrer et qui peut dire ça mais
sans mettre une laine
je suis dit que celui qui a dit frappée
et l'on vous ouvrira
[Musique]
fermez les rideaux nos amis au muscat
et maintenant très vite les dames le
coefficient vous donner à ce gag du
petit baigneur très très vite vite un
chiffre pendant que nos deux amis dans
leur cabine sont en train de chercher de
leur attention je vous donne 10 secondes
pour le faire vite vite vite vite vite
attention alors voulez vous ouvrir les
rideaux maintenant pour voir si les
chiffres sont les mêmes
voilà monsieur abbas et attention alors
là alors l'arrêt diminé monsieur marc
voilà éliminé toute façon alors là vous
avez vous avez le chiffre alors là ici
où nous devions 5,9 sait plus quoi faire
c'est pas la même chose d'autre à ben
alors là je suis dans une si vous
n'aviez pas entendu monsieur markov
saviez pas ce qu'ils devaient faire vous
étiez en train de dormir tous mes yeux
qu'un vous êtes non vous n'êtes pas dans
la cabine des courants d'air vous êtes
dans une autre cabine je porte
bah écoutez je crois que pour qu'est ce
que nous allons faire pire lui en donne
quand même un écureuil à l'équipier la
plus proche n'ont alors dont un écureuil
ils ont suivi on donne un écureuil
monsieur madame pliquet quoi d'ailleurs
de toute façon vous allez pouvoir vous
consoler tout de suite parce qu'après
monsieur le curé voici monsieur demers
avez-vous bien écoutez monsieur r voilà
[Musique]
et pour ce test et bien rassurez vous
c'est fini la pénitence est terminée
quand il est question de mer encore plus
culture et d'ailleurs on retrouve son
époux voilà il va vous 32 bras pour
gagner vos 2e place le v vous madame
messieurs vous avez pas tromper tout
fait là dedans non tout allait bien ça
va vous refaites surface offrait le bras
madame affret qu'est ce qui s'est passé
monsieur mark of lauryn en changeait pas
ah mais si je l'avais dit d'ailleurs
pourtant c'est dommage enfin écoutez
vous prenez vos places vous vous
installez et ce mr que je vous ai
annoncé bien c'est un des plus célèbres
d'ailleurs vous allez vous le constatez
vous même
voici monsieur le maire henri tisot
[Musique]
eh bien je suis très heureux ce soir
et même très ému de quitter pour
quelques trop court instant hélas mais
hautes fonctions et toutes les
responsabilités qui sont attachés à la
personne mais je suis très heureux car
sur l'invitation de monsieur guy lux je
me revient jouer un rôle très agréable
celui d'un maire d'une commune de france
rôle qui permet d'unir toutes les
françaises et les français qui sait mais
je me suis laissé dire que beaucoup de
jeunes époux n'écoutait que d'une
oreille distraite
le colt et les articles que le maire de
leur commune était tenu leur lit aussi
brevet en lire 3 dont l'un est faux car
mais secrétaire
mes secrétaires quitterait espié de
nature analyser un volontairement
inexacts
alors je mourrai voulez lire article 1er
écoutez bien les époux se doivent
mutuellement fidélité secours assistance
article 2 le mari et le chef de famille
il exerce cette fonction dans l'intérêt
commun du ménage et tes enfants
article 3 le joies de la résidence de la
famille est fixée d'un commun accord
la femme est obligée d'habiter avec son
mari et il est tenu de la shoah
d'après vous elle est là
[Musique]
si on interdise maintenant de participer
à un jeu si vous permettez c'est moi qui
vais maintenant donner les 15 secondes
habituel à nos candidats pour qu'il
puisse nous dire respectivement quels
articles qui leur a paru faux monsieur
madame markov s'est offert les écouter
je crois que c'est le troisième parce
qu'il se sent pas son mari qui diraient
les raisons permettez que je passe pas
d'opinion voyez à gauche à droite
monsieur madame oui ben on va faire pour
quoi que je fais exprès mais je pense
que c'est également le troisième
monsieur le maire je crois qu'il ne me
reste plus qu'à féliciter ses deux
coupes fort sympathique et bien français
bravo merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et je vous dis pour faire venir épargné
effet beaucoup proches
merci
merci henri tisot est bien le score
puisque vous avez tous les deux à
nouveau kerry un écureuil en réalité
c'était 2 cette fois parce que c'était
une épreuve de connaissances et deux
écureuils vous récompense par conséquent
je pense que maintenant on a une petite
erreur ce devrait être 5 à 4,6 5,6 à
cette voie là est bien le tableau est
complètement perdue on va essayer de 6
pour monsieur madame pliquet 5 pour
monsieur et madame markov très bien et
bien maintenant notre septième test
êtes-vous à la page
[Musique]
regardez sur cet écran est bien cinq
événements vont apparaître
et pour cela vous nous allons vous
demander de prendre en main les petites
lettres qui sont tendus par aux hôtesses
auquel vous allez retrouver les lettres
correspondantes aux événements je tiens
à vous préciser que deux des événements
qui vont vous être présentés ont eu lieu
la même année
vous devrez brandir lorsque j'aurai
compter jusqu'à trois points 5e et
événements les deux lettres
correspondant à ces deux événements qui
ont eu lieu la même année était les
cinémas
en mai voyage de france l'oeuvre
rio-de-janeiro lettre f correspondante à
la lettre c voici la clôture du concile
jeudi à la clôture du concile vatican ii
de rome correspond à la lettre c'est
qu'on vous a remises événement numéro 3
gagarine premier homme de l'espace à
bord de vostok 1 correspond tout
naturellement à la lettre logique vous a
également été remise
evènement numéro 4 john et jackie
kennedy à paris correspondant à la
lettre k souvenez vous cette phrase
merveilleuse du président kennedy qui
dit je suis le monsieur qui accompagne
jackie kennedy à paris c'était un époux
très courtois et enfin correspondant à
la lettre o c'est-à-dire olympiades
voici le un très court extrait du slalom
victorieux de kylie aux jeux olympiques
[Musique]
fcg ko deux lettres pourtant
correspondent à deux événements de la
même année attention lorsque j'aurai
compté jusqu'à 3 monsieur même markov me
suis même pliquet vous devrez lever les
deux lettres qui correspondent à ces
deux événements qui ont eu lieu dans la
même année années que je vous le verrez
dans quelques instants
attention 1 2 3 f k pour monsieur
cliquer gk et pour monsieur markov
victoire à monsieur markov
gk gagarine programme premier homme de
l'espace 12 avril 1961
je n'ai jackie kennedy à paris le 3 juin
1961 petite erreur qui fait que d'un
seul coup eh bien monsieur même piqué
qui tenait la tête se trouvent distancés
d'un écureuil voilà que maintenant ça
devient un match voyait jusqu'à
maintenant c'était un affrontement
amical maintenant c'est un match
d'autant plus approchant de la fin
regardons le score qui en principe fin
justement nous révéler
que maintenant monsieur mark of men par
7 à 6 alors que je vais vous demander un
petit peu de culture physique de quitter
vos fauteuils de vous rendre sur ses
tables honneur quand voici le huitième
test savez vous que prenez les chemins
les plus courts merci infiniment aux
hôtesses vont nous conduire établir un
budget établir un budget c'est d'abord
bien connaître le prix des choses ce qui
est certainement votre corps vous voulez
absolument pas aller au tableau noir de
fumée à me piquer l'école c'est terminé
pour vous eh bien nous espérons que
c'est votre cas car si vous établissez
bien votre budget eh bien vous dépensez
le minimum
conclusion il faut savoir faire des
économies que vous placerez d'ailleurs
tout naturellement sur votre livret de
caisse d'épargné de prévoyance
d'ailleurs ce test nous a été inspirée
par les caisses d'epargne et de
prévoyance qui s'intéresse beaucoup au
budget familial
vous avez vu regardez vous avez une
addition comme une affaire où nous avons
sournoisement mélanger des produits qui
sont en général acheté par vous mesdames
et d'autres qui sont plus
particulièrement masculin
vous allez avoir 45 secondes pour faire
vos addition attention nos amis
téléspectateurs vont voir sur leurs
écrans la même chose comme ça tout le
monde pourra jouer ici chez soi pour 45
secondes chrono m
bien entendu nous avons les bons
chiffres en dessous qui m'étonne 1 j'ai
eu peur j'ai cru que ma impliqué vous a
déjà le total avant d'avoir mis les
chiffres intermédiaires
c'est vraiment un travail d'équipé
regardez monsieur markov a déjà empêché
madame markov de faire des blagues
d'ailleurs eemeaa de la place d'un zéro
par contre du côté de monsieur même
impliqué chacun travaille pour soi et on
en est déjà l'addition il ne reste plus
que 15 15 à 20 secondes dépêchez vous
monsieur madame markov qui va être le
plus près de la vérité
[Musique]
250 g de beurre un paquet de gauloises
10 litres de super 200 g de semences de
tapissier 100 km en chemins de fer
français bien sûr deuxième classe 500 g
de faufile attention c'est terminé pas
de regrets 1 2 3 attention c'est terminé
pierre louis va gagner lalanne
l'addition de monsieur madame markov
alors que monsieur madame marcotte vont
regagner leur place ainsi que monsieur
impliqué vous êtes en train de discuter
c'est vrai pardon
vous avez oublié 1 0 ah ben c'est un peu
dallas les mettez le quand même vous
n'avez rien oublié monsieur madame
markov parce qu'ils ont oublié 1 0 nous
sommes prêts à vous concéder un zéro de
plus ou moins 0 2 mois on n'est pas à
zéro pourrait d'ailleurs pierre
oui eh bien moi j'ai du boeny va nous
donner un petit peu le détail de
l'addition de semaine marc g du beurre à
2,80 je vous laisse le paquet de
gauloises 1,55 les 10 litres à 12,20 les
semences à 0,60 les 100km en chemin de
fer pour 10 francs et les 542 faufilait
9,50 le tout le tout 36 65 mais voyons
d'abord un peu le détail si vous voulez
des des prix comme cela avait là les
frais
voilà les vrais prix regardez les 3 10 1
50 ont 60 de 70 cents cinquante neuf
francs et le total
candice patou dans 27 francs 30
c'est pas ça fait un mal à 18 18 alors
écoutez mon faufilez vous faufilez vous
en france il a augmenté un peu à 70,39
carence le to hope 940 le tout moi je
peux pas vous laissez moi pardon maglica
39 40
c'est mon dernier prix étant donné que
j'ai deux francs 60 pour les 250 g de
beurre à francin comme pour les gaulois
10 70 pour le super g c'est zéro franc
81 pour les semences de tapissier g qui
sautent qui fit 140 francs pour les
100km en chemin de fer et j'ai 10 francs
pour le faux filet nous avons une
addition de 145 france et ça c'est pas
du tout ce nom vous avez fait une faute
édition retourne à l'école de toute
façon nous allons maintenant voir 145
francs alors que forcément mon édition
est rigoureusement la même que celle de
pierre louis c'est à dire elle est
également de 39 ans 40 il eût été
étonnant avec les mêmes produits lehman
et du premier coup pour vous bon et moi
je 145 euros
et vous vous avez combien qu'est ce que
vous voulez savoir j'ai un total de 145
francs j'avais un total de 145 fois où
ça bah oui le tabac vol alors attendez
moi j'ai à vous dire mais va tout est
tombé j'ai plus de total volet non mais
je voudrais je voudrais bien comparer
avec mauvais alors à 36,65 important
quoi détruire et j'en suis sûr
travestissent la fête sera présent moi
j'ai rien enfin chez n'importe quoi et
filles c'est bien ça son canal a nommé
le plus proche je vous en prie merci
alors je vais gagner 2 kg
j'avoue normal
il est indiscutable nationale barkoff
qui avec votre addition vous étiez
finalement très près de la vérité
félicitations qu'est ce qui s'est passé
je suis maintenant on a rajouté 1 0 il
ajouté mais la demande était juste que
j'y trouvais pas de match là c'est ce
qu'on appelle être troublé par les
caméras par le jeu parce que finalement
vous devez certainement très bien réglé
votre budget famille à deux écureuils de
plus pour monsieur madame markov qui se
détache presque irrésistiblement alors
que maintenant le score est de 9 à 6
tout n'est pas perdu car il y encore un
test forte important etes-vous bon juge
[Musique]
autant vous le dire maintenant notre
distribution d'écureuil touche à sa fin
vous savez qu on en distribue 13 au
maximum après ce test il en restera deux
distribués c'est un petit peu tangente
pour monsieur madame impliqués néanmoins
regarder bien sûr ce grand écran une
silhouette va apparaître vous avez 20
questions pour deviner qui est ce à
chacune de vos questions le personnage
mystérieux vous répondra soit par oui ou
non
heureusement la tête comme ceux-ci
personnage mystérieux n'entendez-vous
personnage mystérieux souhaiteriez-vous
m'entendre encore plus quoi me voilà
peux pas être plus heureux c'est un
petit détail de ce règlement bien sûr ce
sera monsieur markov qui posera la
première question puisque vous êtes en
tête monsieur cliquer la seconde madame
markov la troisième
madame pic est la quatrième et ainsi de
suite jusqu'à épuisement des vingt
questions mais en cours de route pour
essayer de battre vos adversaires vous
pouvez quand même tenter d'identifier en
posant la question la question que vous
êtes mais seulement si cette réponse est
mauvais si on vous répond pas non vous
avez perdu toute place dans notre jeu et
vous êtes éliminés donc vous n'avez
droit qu'à une seule réponse par
personne c'est clair c'est compris
attention monsieur markov pour 3 minutes
le jeu est partie votre première
question
monsieur mickey etes-vous chanteuse de
music hall madame markov
troisième question est-elle marié vous
lui posez la question c'est pas moi de
vous répondre
êtes vous mariée mal appliquée êtes vous
une chanteuse comique à yale vous a
répondu vous avez toujours le droit tout
moment a donné la réponse si vous pensez
avoir trouvé la réponse dit monsieur
markov cinquième question monde
monsieur vous avez vous les posez la
question dans trop tard dit monsieur
pliquet monsieur cliquer êtes vous
mariée avec une loupe une vedette
non a répondu madame markov et vous deux
enfants même piqué faites-vous de
l'opérette vous voulez vous donner la
réponse à l'ordre il dicte vous êtes
annie cordy annie cordy gagner pour
monsieur impliqué amis tandis
qu'apparaît
ah oui
annie cordy que vous avez des couples
qui le connaissent j'ai pensé un moment
que monsieur madame markov avait saisi 1
et paraît finalement je crois que vous
avez tort pas posé la question vous
l'aviez sur le bout des lèvres
annie cordy de trois petites questions
n'ont pas conjugales vous étiez de
passage c'est gentil j'ai vu des
lumières je suis venu voilà très bien
vous avez terminé quoi vous allez
commencer quoi les liens j'ai terminé
une tournée de deux cent dix jours sans
vie lance en dix jours et puis voilà
j'ai pris un petit peu de vacances et je
repars pour montréal pour une télévision
à genève pour une télévision
et puis je commencerai au moins deux
phares de la fin octobre la répétition
de ma comédie burlesque avec mon ami
pierre d'horus vous êtes marié marié
qu'elle est plus patient des deux chez
vous je crois que c'est mon mari qui
chante le mieux des deux alors là je
veux dire que c'est moi alors puisque
vous chantez mieux c'est pour ça que
nous allons vous demander maintenant
l'interpréter une de vos dernières
chansons mais il y a 6 ans joue dans
tous mes joueurs impénitent ici alors
vous allez messieurs nos hôtesses vont
vous remettre un carton vous n'aurez
jamais l'occasion d'écouter annie cordy
tranquille avec un crayon feutre et vous
allez noter demo je dis bien dit mot au
moins de la chanson qu interprète annie
cordy et qui est qui est permettait
s'ignorent et annie cordy vous dire
après ce que vous faites c'est demo
permettait signora il suffit de lire un
journal
pour dénicher l'homme idéal
j'ai rencontré à rome ou non ou non je
vous passe les détails
l agence matrimoniale
j'avais déjà une rivale elle voulait pas
mon futur en apprendre que j'en ai et se
défendra
c'est signant la demande et aux autres
j'étais près de la porte j'ai thèse
avant vous m
des signes on la désigne en attendre
celui-là je l'entends il sort
mais les cinémas c'est vrai
il fait ce
l'arrêté
ce matin
permet
des signes on la défend
entre suis là je l'on pense qu'il sera
mon époux poignet
j'ai flippé porn par le bras je lui dis
épouse et moi
[Musique]
je fus si convaincante troublante pas
dante qui n'a pas eu le choix
mais quand jour des noces arrive à ma
rivale était donc là elle voulait
embrasser mon nom mais plein de bonnets
ou la chaudronne deux fois celle mais
des signes ans la donne
et aux autres j'étais près de la porta
jeu
non
permettent et signant là
[Musique]
on a d'autres celui-là je l'emporté qui
sait
mais des seniors messieurs
tellement
et signant la gelée vu la première alors
rien à faire
je lui passe la corde au cou
[Musique]
maintenant on est un peu dans l'ambiance
du parc et un ami on va nous apporter un
micro oui une chaise un fauteuil d'avion
des rats pendant que nous demandons à
monsieur marcotte de bien vouloir nous
et non c'est très lentement et aux
doigts pour que ça puisse être marqué
sur notre synthétiseur et que les
téléspectateurs jouer avec nous les dix
mots qu'il a choisis alors journal
mission d'un homme idéal et les agences
ça m'intrigue patrimoniale matrimoniale
corps à truites pour que notre sténo
là-bas en coulisses puisque ep nommé
oubliée portes jeudi à dimanche époux et
signera signera épouse enos
ils s'épousent enos largement les
maintenant vers monsieur madame clic et
vous restez la chirurgie et je m'en doit
me suis appliquée d'annoncer au droit
aussi sans sa liste alors journal idéal
hommes à leur journal
idea idéal hommes noces détail détail
agence agences rivales rival coucou otc
rue bien sûr une autre autre époux et
épouses moi j'en attends les doubistes
mettant en place je crois qu'on va vous
dire messieurs ce qu'annie cordy vous a
réservé et bien voilà je vais vous poser
des questions et vous allez essayer de
me répondre par un des mots que vous
avez là n'est ce pas alors on choisirait
il ya cinq questions est-ce qu'il ya
minutage qui pour ça je vais nommer les
minutes oulala alors on part vous êtes
près d'accord alors que pensez vous d'un
homme qui trompe sa femme agence
matrimoniale
peut-être eu bon dos mais vous à gauche
ou à droite de votre femme et homme
idéal faut dire j'ai passé deux secondes
pour et pour dire je suis intransigeant
vérifiez vous l'amenez que vous rend
votre femme idéale
regardez vous les femmes dans la rue
attention seniors 1 6 ignore a dit
monsieur comment appelez vous votre
épouse dans l'intimité
alors là c'est facile épouse est
terminée très peu de temps après je
regarde ça sur mon cher je suis vous
m'auriez envie de rester encore un bon
moment à côté de monsieur markov mais
enfin à vous cher monsieur
première question acceptez vous que
votre femme porte un monokini
l'idéal savez vous ce que contient le
sac à main de votre femme des feuilles
combien de fois par jour embrasser vous
votre femme coup
demandez lui ce que ça veut dire qu'est
ce que ça veut dire aussi je
l'embrassais et ben voilà ce qu'il
fallait dire bravo quatrième question
lui servez vous le petit déjeuner au lit
époux époux ça veut dire quoi ça comme
un bonus à 5
lequel des deux a proposé le mariage
sommes aidés dont vous avez un sacré
vocabulaire époux coup aube vous
n'auriez pas pu agrémenter sa de
quelques verbes en fait quelque chose
non il il déjà très fatigué et bien je
crois que les deux points afin le point
pardon puisqu'il s'agit d'un point va à
monsieur et madame pitt est très bien et
bien bravo ma chère et bravo je vous dis
bon soir dans sa ville
voilà je crois que maintenant nous
regardons le dernier score de la soirée
qui confirme par un score extrêmement
serré d'ailleurs la victoire de monsieur
markov qui bat monsieur même pitt l'aide
d'un petit d'un petit pois alors écoutez
autant vous dire monsieur même pitelet
que vous avez raté votre entrée m'enfin
vous ne raterez pas votre sortie parce
que maintenant vous avez gagné la
sympathie de tous les téléspectateurs
j'ai l'impression est que non seulement
vous ayez la sympathie mais vous avez
également gagné un petit livret de
caisse d'epargne de consolation bien sûr
on ne vient jamais ici pour rien voilà
votre déçu non un petit peu déçue et
vous pensiez rester là pour plusieurs
semaines on savait qu'il avoue c'est
dommage ça va toujours être un
déchirement pour nous de perdre un
couple parce que déjà on a l'impression
qu'il fait partie de la famille enfin
vous restez là pour la fin de l'émission
car maintenant voici le moment venu de
demander à monsieur et madame markov
d'affronter le dernier test le sésame
[Musique]
et bien en effet oui c'est très
important vous installer en face de moi
on va vous apporter un micro c'est une
épreuve de connaissance après tout il
faut bien après tant de tests d'hiver
voici vos écureuils et voici votre micro
savoir si votre couple
monsieur markov possède deux les vertus
d'un lauréat de l'homme du 20e siècle
ce tableau comporte 13 mots cachés ces
13 mots essentiels constitué un
événement très très connu
universellement connu peut-on dire vous
avez le droit de retourner
autant de mots que vous avez d'écureuil
à votre actif c'est-à-dire 8 écureuils
c'est vous dire n'offrent plus dur sur
sur trets écureuils vous allez quand
même à voir que quatre mots cachés si
vous ne trouvez pas mais je tiens à vous
dire que si vous ne trouvez pas vous
êtes éliminés ce test à deux importants
s'ils vous ouvre ce qu'on sait que nous
l'appelons le sésame les portes la
semaine prochaine et ils valorisent vos
écureuil en première semaine bon disons
que ce n'est pas énorme sans fond
l'écureuil en deuxième semaine
l'écureuil devient 500 francs en 3e 12
150 ans 4e 2005 et en 5e 5000 francs un
écureuil de près d'un demi million
d'anciens francs avril quand même c'est
quand même quelque chose surtout si vous
en avez six sept huit ou neuf comme ce
soir
mais attention si au moment où nous
déclenchons chronomètre et vous n'aurez
que 45 secondes ce soir pour deviner cet
événement de 13 mo vous pensez que si
vous avez la réponse vous me donner
cette réponse si elle est mauvaise
alors vous aurez encore la possibilité
de me donner d'autres réponses en
n'achetant les derniers mots cachés en
maintenant des écureuils
j'espère que vous n'en arriverait pas là
attention vous avez maintenant trente
secondes pour retourner les huit cartes
auxquelles vous avez droit
allez-y neuf cartes pardon je veux
absolument que vous ne l'ayez que 8
dépêchez-vous très vite voulait
retourner ensemble c'est toujours un
travail un travail
l'équipe
il ne vous reste plus que dix secondes
attention 1 2 dont on n'est pas plus
qu'il n'en faut 5 et 4 nov retourner à
votre place c'est terminé vous alliez en
tournée alors attention maintenant pour
45 secondes chrono m
de quoi s'agit-il
[Musique]
le tunnel du monde
il s'agit de
oui c'est ça c'est une bulle du mont
blanc le biais des creuseurs avec les
italiens
et français réponse exacte
la phrase
ms il aimait les 13 e vo vous aviez eu
la main heureuse en à mon avis en
retournant au sommet km italiens
français voici la fois connue la ration
des techniciens français et italiens il
permet d'économiser parade automation
100 km de route grâce à un ouvrage sous
le plus haut sommet d'europe
inauguré en 1965 vous n'avez pas eu
besoin de me donner les écureuils pour
rester avec nos écureuils venait jusqu'à
moi puisque maintenant c'est le moment
de nous séparer
monsieur madame markov vous êtes
définitivement gagnant dgcs micro on
vous applaudit où c'est une brillante
nous pouvons dire nous pouvons dire
vacances c'est une victoire de normandie
puisque j'avais gardé ça pour la bonne
bouche vous êtes je crois du roi cessé
mais la région d'oran dont les rouennais
vont être heureux que le rebelle et
brillamment représenté vous savez que
vous ne pouvez pas à bordeaux mais en
première semaine pour revenir la semaine
prochaine les écureuils seront à 500
francs et vous serez opposé à un couple
de jeunes parisiens dont le nom sera
révélé d'ailleurs à la presse sous
quelques heures parce que nous en avons
trop quatre qui sont très près l'un de
l'autre et qui ont probablement assister
à l'émission ce soir ils se disent voilà
le point faible de ce groupe pour
essayer d arsenal
vous direz peut-être cinq semaines les
tests ne sont pas les mêmes mais de
toute façon ne vous inquiétez pas un
livret de caisse d'épargné de prévoyance
le deuxième sur lequel nous inscrivons 9
x 10,9 x 100 français hier les écuries
de ce soir votre mii et avec un intérêt
extraordinaire vous inquiétez pas si
vous êtes éliminés en 2e 3e 4e semaine
vous le trouvez là il aura fait des
petits je crois que vous pouvez quand
même allé consoler bien sûr oui ça fait
tilt adversaires qui ont été battus que
d'un écureuil
c'est ainsi que sur ces effusions très
amicale nous allons nous séparer amis de
la vie à deux à samedi prochain
merci de votre attention
[Musique]